salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par norvpn hey c'est bientôt les
vacances et justement norvpn permet de
changer votre emplacement virtuel pour
pouvoir accéder à n'importe quel contenu
dans n'importe quel pays pour par
exemple continuer à regarder TF1 depuis
un pays étranger quoi il est pas bon mon
argument mais aussi de chiffrer votre
activité en ligne sur Internet et aussi
votre position pour la masquer auprès de
petits curieux avec N VPN
[Musique]
SP et
voilà oh [ __ ] j'ai pas esquivé mon
[Musique]
vpnor VPN propose également un nouveau
service
c'est c'est le nouveau serviceim de
norvp qui vous permet de surfer à
l'étranger comme si vous aviez une carte
SIM locale sans faire exploser votre
budget avec N VPN ah ben j'ai utilisé le
VPN pour télécharger l'intégral du
Seigneur des Anneaux versions longue on
va pouvoir enfin faire autre chose que
de regarder ces fleurs de
merde sonur
[Musique]
VPN et voilà sans traction eh tu vois
qu'on est pas obligé de regarder le
seigneur des anneau profiter de norvpen
cet été avec 4 mois offerts sur tous les
abonnements de 2 ans et bénéficier
jusqu'à 20 Go de de Data sur s offre
valable en utilisant le code joueur
satisfait ou rembourser les 30 premiers
jours jusqu'à 10 appareils en simultané
ok ça tourne allez c'est
parti tu es prêt ouais me pas tu fais
pas mal 3 2
1 bonjour je suis de la Direction
générale des finances publiques je peux
rentrer quelques minutes oui oui allez-y
rentrez
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur grenier c'est bien
ça je suis au regret de vous informer
qu'il y a visiblement un petit problème
sur votre déclaration justificative de
revenu sur l'année 2023
comment ça déclaration d'impôt mais je
l'ai fait l'année dernière oui je l'ai
ici d'ailleurs mais il y a peut-être une
[Musique]
anomalie pourtant tout ça a l'air en
règle vous avez mis la mauvaise date
malheureusement et du coup qu'est-ce qui
va se passer et bien comme je vous
disais nous allons entamer une procédure
de recouvrement de vos créances qui
remettront vos biens à l'autorité
administrative
ah ça va ok j'ai cru que vous alliez
tout nous prendre c'est exactement ce
qu'on vient de
faire vache vachement rapide et efficace
mais je peux déposer un recours
évidemment voilà un dossier d'ouverture
de demande pour un recours on vous
répondra sous 46 mois et si c'est validé
il faudra que vous passiez en personne à
la préfecture de Mayotte de Mayenne non
Mayotte pour obtenir une date de
rendez-vous téléphonique en vue de la
création d'un dosser subsidiaire à la
préfecture est toujours c'est ça
toujours et [ __ ] mais on fait quoi du
coup t'inquiète j'ai pu caché ça
ah merde vas-y ils ont tout pris ils ont
laissé que les trucs qui ont aucune
[Musique]
valeur pardon je suis dans le
champ bon
allez c'est pas mal
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a déjà parlé plusieurs fois de la 3DO
par le passé Shadow war of succession la
version de dragonler qu'on avait testé
corps killer mais on s'est jamais
vraiment arrêté pour parler de la
console elle-même il est donc temps de
le faire mais avant de parler de la 3DO
je dois vous parler de trip Hawkins
c'est lui non ça c'est un pied
d'éclairage ah oui regarde
mieux l'histoire commence au début des
années 80 lorsque trip Hawkins ancien
chef du marketing chez Apple décide de
créer sa propre société et cette société
vous la connaissez puisque c'est
Electronic
Arts avant que Electronic Arts ne
devienn une succursale de l'enfer mais
début 90 tripoins sans le vent tourner
dans le milieu du jeu vidéo et décide de
créer une autre société nommée 3
les yeux dans les yeux alors 3D ça veut
dire quoi finalement bah en fait il faut
remonter à comment a été choisi le nom
de la console lors de sa présentation à
la convention de Las Vegas en 1992 elle
n'a pas encore de nom mais je vous
présente notre nouvelle console
3D attends mais ça me donne une idée
tout ça super sear bref tripokins
voulait faire évoluer le milieu du jeu
vidéo déjà en proposant une console avec
la puissance d'un PC par exemple on
déplace des image 50 fois plus
rapidement qu'un PC 486 mais également
en changeant les méthodes ayant jusque-
là cours dans l'industrie il faut savoir
que le marché des jeux vidéos depuis
Nintendo a toujours fonctionné sur le
même modèle les constructeurs vendent la
machine à perte mais se refond de
l'argent sur les jeux et les produit
dérivés 3DO en revanche veut faire autre
chose l'idée c'est de breveter le
concept même de la 3DO pour autoriser
plusieurs constructeurs à fabriquer la
machine un petit peu à la manière des
cartes graphiques NVIDIA vous savez qu'
peuvent être autant des Asus que des
gigabyt ou des MSI mais pour qu'une
console fonctionne il faut bien sûr des
jeux et pour ça 3DO a une idée sur
comment attirer les éditeurs leur
technique c'est qu'un éditeur qui
sortirait un jeu sur 3D n'aurait inversé
que trois pauvres dollars de royalties
par jeu vendu au constructeur de la
machine un deal vraiment intéressant à
l'époque puisque non seulement c'est
moins cher que les autres consoles mais
en plus le coût de fabrication des jeux
sur CD était dérisoire par rapport au
jeux sur cartouche et à ça il faut
rajouter que techniquement la 3DO était
censé être monstre
un lecteur de CD r bien plus rapide que
le megga CD plein de couleurs nous avons
également 16 millions de couleurs
comparé au disons 256 des jeux sur PC et
bien sûr la vidéo qui faisait défaut au
console à cartouche à tel point qu'au
début même Sony hésite à acquérir la
licence de la 3DO mais comme en interne
le développement de la Playstation a
déjà commencé l'idée sera vite abandonné
la console est donc lancée le 3 octobre
1993 au prix dérisoire de 700 dollars
combien
ouais en calculant avec l'inflation ça
fait 1400 €. combien ça part mal hein le
titre de lancement de la console était
censé être Jurassic Park interactive he
pour surfer sur le succès du film mais
le jeu arrivera en retard et c'est crash
and burn qui d'ailleurs sera le tout
premier titre de crrystal dynamics les
futurs créateurs de Tomb Raider qui
restera le seul titre de lancement
pendant prs de 4 mois oui ça va on a
compris quand un Jurassic Park et bien
le jeu arrivera en retard mais
malheureusement les couilles frère le
jeu s'ouvre sur des images du film avec
la vraie musique du film
[Musique]
oui oui c'est la vraie musique du film
pris bref jusque là tout
[Musique]
va attendez qui sont ces gens
excusez-moi qui êtes-vous ah mais je
reconnais c'est Jurassic carp c'est Alan
Brant chatler et Ganou bref dans le jeu
vous êtes en charge du système de
sécurité de l'île c'est un peu night
trap avec des dinosaures quoi night trap
avec des dinosaures
[Musique]
donc Denis N a saboté le système les
travailleurs et les visiteurs sont
bloqués sur l'île et c'est donc à nous
que revient la tâche de sauver tout le
monde en utilisant l'ordinateur de
[Musique]
nedri alors mes attentes étaient basses
hein pourtant mais euh waouh bon alors
bon bah c'est de la merde je crois que
ça mérite pas vraiment plus
d'explication que ça on va plutôt donc
aller voir les autres personnages qu'on
doit diriger dans le parc pour les
emmener en sécurité avec à chaque fois
bien sûr des petites scènes vidéo
originales et inédites qui débordent de
budget pipi pipi pipi pipi pipi on a
donc plusieurs miniux hein dont un avec
les
dilophosaures qui meurt de façon très
réaliste un jeu où on doit fuir le T-Rex
en pilotant une voiture et en évitant
les squelettes de dinosaures sur la
route et les jeeps renversés monsieur
j'ai pas fini de laver vos vitres
attends des squelettes de dinosaures et
des jeeps renversés oui oui est-ce qu'on
pourrait ne pas en parler dans cette
interview s'il vous plaît mais on notera
au passage le degré de Ba he puisqueà
chaque fois le jeu t'annonce des
nouveaux lieux du parc que tu vas
visiter alors que c'est juste les trois
mêmes JS en boucle maison de John
amonde
garage porte de Jurassic Park enclos des
brachosaures oh mon dieu les brachosant
ont été dévorés par les dophosures c'est
un véritable
cauchemar oh mon dieu mais il a raison
ah oui et d'ailleurs quand ton père le
jeu nous dit que les dinosaures ont
atterri sur le continent oui comment ils
ont volé l'hélico et la double punition
à la fin quand même avec une petite
séquence de cauchemar sur les crédits du
jeu je souffre ah ça fait tellement mal
bref pas besoin de vous dire que le jeu
fut pas spécialement le succès attendu
et ce n'est pas le reste du catalogue 3D
qui allait aider hein parce que si sur
le papier mettre des royalties très
faibles sur les ventes de jeux c'est une
bonne idée puisque ça permet aux plus
petits éditeurs de pouvoir publier leur
jeux l'inconvénient c'est que ça permet
aux plus petits éditeurs de pouvoir
publier leur jeux comme virtuoso par
exemple un jeu sorti en 94 alors bon le
jeu commence directement sur Mars avec
ses mouches géantes ses araignées son
oxygène B je vais pas tout détailler
vous savez à quoi ressemble mars c'est
fou parce que on entend jamais son
personnage he parler dans le jeu mais je
sens quand même que le mec a cette
voix-l putting la semaine dernière on
est allé au maomin avec Gigi les copings
on s'est mis la race Conand bon alors
c'est un TPS vous l'avez compris et
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est que c'est
décor bordel et pour mieux comprendre on
va faire une visite à l'intérieur du
colon on a un colon géant ici alors on y
va on y va les symptômes c'est du sang
dans les selles une modification du
récent du transit diarré consumation des
douleurs abdominales mon passage
qu'est-ce qu'on fout là juste je suis un
mec en blouson de cuir sur Mars qui tire
avec des flingues sur des araignées dans
un sous-sol en forme de steak acheté et
je ramasse des croix égyptiennes sur un
fond musical de métal libre de droit
mais Jean-Louis concentrez-vous un peu
sur le développement du jeu et arrêtez
de me raconter vos rêves parce attends
la musique on en parler 2 secondes alors
ok je m'attendais pas à avoir assz d'ESS
en BO mais le jeu s'appel virtuoso avec
une petite guitare sur leev on est quand
même en droit de s'attendre un minimum
alors
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai l'impression
d'être un monde marçant à 19h20 le jour
de la fête de la musique là ah oui et
d'ailleurs vous connaissez le principe
des hallucinations
auditives évidment j'ai parler du jeu
vidéo en lui-même alors c'est de la
merde pour pleine raison que voici en
accéléré l'interface du menu est
dégueulasse cet écran de chargement fait
piquer pour des anque égyptien est
incompréhensible personnage est long les
ennemis arrivent dans mon dos enlève-moi
cette serpillère de ta tête VO rien à
cause du
brouillardccem sont des mouettes c'est
une
blague sérieusement on est en quelle
année là qu'est-ce que c'est que ces
merd et quelle est la logique de toute
cette merde me direz-vous pourquoi
peut-on respirer sur Mars ou affronter
des bommes de neige dans une maison
hentée et ben il y en a pas c'est parce
qu'en fait le jeu vidéo se passe dans un
monde virtuel pourquoi il y a des crabes
sur Mars c'est un monde virtuel et avec
ça c'est magique tuexpliques tout les
mini cartes dans le jeu sont à chié et
n'indiquent rien virtuel les corbeaux
font des bruits de pigeon pour aucune
[ __ ] de raison virtuel est
différent les portes empêchent de finir
le niveau parce qu'elles sont
ridiculement rapides V i r il est fort
mais la 3DO c'était aussi le théâtre de
jeux plus expérimentaux et pas toujours
réussi par exemple Peter Frankel alors
celui-là est surréaliste hein vous êtes
dans une rue en France et on dirait un
rêve fiévreux où ton cerveau aurait
assemblé des trucs pris au hasard il y a
des clown des artistes de rue des
jongleurs ouais bon bref c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est pas terrible hein et
puis bon si je veux voir ça je peux
juste aller devant n'importe quel fac de
lettre hein je prends la cravate comme
ceci 4000
bon peut-être pas n'importe quel fac de
lettre alors en voyant cette flopppée de
jeu de merde on comprend que le plan de
trip Hawkins est décidément bien parti
en couille non seulement la megga driive
et la SuperNes résistent mais elles font
même bien mieux que résister puisquen 94
c'est une des meilleures années de la
Super NES et la console enchaîne les
titres de légende super Buten 2 meggaan
x donong country secret of Manas super
metroï tout ça ce sont des titres sortis
en 1994 alors avec un prix délirant et
un catalogue de jeux à chier la 3DO est
donc condamné à mourir du coup qui qui
sait qu'on appelle pour la
sauver la 3DO c'est la console du cul
littéralement dans tous les sens du
terme la machine a tout un tas de titres
qui ne sont en réalité que des films
érotiques mis sur CD avec des gros noms
connus comme vivide Entertainment avec
leur petit logo de l'époque là oh [ __ ]
la vache la pauvre et on va pas tous se
les faire déjà parce que je vais pas
faire bannir cette chaîne mais aussi
parce que j'ai juste à vous montrer les
boîtes de jeu pour que vous compreniez
ce qu'il y a dedans blonde justice
immortal deser super modèle go wild
endlessly love [ __ ] un jeu érotique avec
des vampires j'aime bien ce titre parce
que bon après il y a aussi des titres
moins imaginatifs genre celui-là sex et
avant que vous me preniez pour un gros
cochon je tiens à préciser que moi ces
jeuxl j'y ai joué avant tout pour le
scénario oui celui-là il a un super
scénario hein par exemple le scénario
c'est elle fait du vélo
après elle arrête de faire du vélo après
elle rigole devant des cactus après fait
du bateau et dans un style s'approchant
il y avait également plusieurs titres
érotiques soft dont le plus connu est
plumbers don'tware ties il y a eu déjà
beaucoup de vidéos qui ont été faite sur
ce jeu et est-ce que ça mérite tout ce
qui a été dit dessus ah et ben je sais
pas pour resituer plers don we Ti est
donc un jeu à très faible budget sorti
sur 3D et très récemment ressorti chez
limited run edition pour la blague c'est
un jeu de merde très très très connu et
ça n'est même pas un FMV classique
puisqu'il n'y a pas de vidéo c'est
simplement un slidhow d'image avec une
voix off par-dessus et de temps en temps
un choix à faire qui n'en sont pas
vraiment non plus puisque si vous faites
le mauvais choix c'est game over bon
alors niveau technique sur ce jeu vous
l'avez vu on est vraiment au niveau de
la soirée diapo chez Mamie alors ça
c'est un jeu de merde sur
3D ça c'est encore le même jeu de merde
sur
3D et si je dis que ça ne mérite pas
toute cette célébrité c'est parce que le
jeu est un anard mais un anard
volontaire genre des fois le narrateur
va se mettre à porter un masque de
poulet pour aucune raison puis il va se
faire casser la gueule par une judocade
sortie de nulle part bref ça n'a
absolument aucun sens et les nanards
volontaires ben c'est un peu de la
triche je trouve en plus c'est même pas
un vrai jeu sexi tous les passages un
peu dénudés sont censurés genre ce que
vous voyez là ça c'est dans le jeu c'est
pas moi qui l'ai rajouté pour YouTube
sérieusement le personnage le plus à
poil que vous verrez dans ce jeu c'est
le vieux en bas de l'image ah oui bon
ben merde tant pis à vu le prix que j'ai
payé la console maintenant rentable
après bon voilà il y a quand même des
vrais trucs foireux genre un choix de
filtre Photoshop un petit peu douteux
pour aucune [ __ ] de raison et une
esthétique un petit peu étrange hein sur
certains
titrages mais en fait tout est tellement
trop raté que tu te dis c'est pas
possible qu'ils ai pas fait exprès genre
par exemple dans le jeu il y a une prise
ratée qui qui est là en entier
[Rires]
bref c'est c'est trop c'est trop c'est
trop raté pour que ce soit pas fait
exprès quand tu joues tu sais jamais si
c'est de la connerie ou du génie absolu
comme les TikTok de Tibo inshape mais
dans les jeux érotiques il y a un pays
qui est passé mettre la matière bien sûr
vous vous en doutez c'est le Kazakhstan
Japon on trouve un catalogue de jeux
érotiqu japonais absolument hallucinant
sur 3DO comme par exemple body con
digital rave party un jeu qui nous
permet de voir les dessous du Japon
C je do dire j'en suis assez fier bon
alors il y a pas de jeu vous l'avez
compris c'est juste des japonaises qui
dansent dans une r party j'ai
l'impression il y a un petit problème
non au niveau du de la caméra c'est pas
très bien
cadré mais bordel je fais ce que je peux
ok d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote c'est un
des seuls jeux que j'ai spedroné
voilà 4 minutes à peu près et on trouve
ça dans plein de styles différents ils
ont même réussi à faire un pierrefeuille
ciseau de cul c'est
[Musique]
dire cette danse m'hypnotise mais je
sais pas
[Musique]
pourquoi vous croyez que c'est fait
exprès vous croyez que c'est un genre de
technique de manipulation
[Musique]
mentale ok c'est bon je vais les porter
les courses mais par pitié arrête de
faire ça mais le Japon ça n'est pas
juste ça attention quiz de de quel titre
provient cette
image a un jeu de drague B un étrange
film de Q japonais amateur c un jeu de
majong d mes vacances en
Thaïlande effectivement il s'agissait
bien de majong connaissez-vous le majong
le majong jeu d'origine chinoise qui se
joue à 4 avec des pièces appelées Tuil
associant tactique stratégie calcul et
psychologie
le majong représente la quintessence de
l'harmonie traditionnelle asiatique et
du cul et le majong paradoxalement bien
que ce soit surtout joué par des vieux
monsieurs Chau qui s'ils étaient
français s'appelleraient Bertrand ou
Tangui ont eu droit à des montagne de
jeux qui n'ont jamais passé la frontière
du Japon jeux vidéo qui presque toujours
m en scène des petites femmes réel ou
non qui ont tendance à vite transpirer
je midentifie tellement à elle donc
voilà je connaissais pas le majong et je
vous avoue que j'ai été un peu surpris
moi-même de découvrir que dans la
sexualité japonaise les joueuses de
majong c'était un petit peu l'équivalent
de nos plombiers bonjour Est-ce que vous
voulez jouer au ma Jong et bien sûr
comme on est au Japon il y a évidemment
aucune limite comme par exemple oyajji
Hunter le héros qui chasse les pervers
avec le majong un jeu de majong certes
mais attendez on va pas quand même juste
se faire chier avec un jeu de majong
tout simple alors euh imaginez alors
c'est des lycéennes qui se font agresser
par des pervers et puis là il y a un
superhéros qui arrive et qui vole au
secours des lycéennes quand elles se
font emmerder dans la rue et et euh et
puis après il joue au majong tous
[Applaudissements]
ensemble
[Musique]
Japon après bon il a l'air plutôt sympa
hein s'il se contentent de juste jouer
au majongue avec eux euh ouais mais
pourquoi quand tu gagnes il a la tête
éclatée alors et ben voilà merci
beaucoup pour cette partie allez bonne
journée ah oui au faitoublé attendez
bien sûr on va pas s'arrêter là on peut
aller plus loin ok alors imaginez c'est
un robot géant qui tire des rayons laser
qui déshabille toutes les
femmes ok vous aimez pas l'idée j'en ai
une autre c'est adolp déguisé en [ __ ]
avec un camion sur lequel il y a marqué
sm j'ai plein d'autres idées
non mais en vrai Seb qu'est-ce qui est
mieux que le cul
Batman alors tu crois pas si bien dire
majong the lady Hunter un autre jeu de
majong un peu sexy avec Batman alors le
mélange est surprenant mais c'est comme
ça le Japon tu dis des mots hasard et ça
existe je trouve ça beaucoup trop drôle
la façon dont Batman intervient quand tu
viens de gagner une partie et que du
coup tu déshabilles la fille
ne la regarde pas regarde-moi les
nichons sont temporaires il faut sauver
cam City bon on peut parler d'autres
choses que le cul ouais ouais non tu as
raison bon allez je suivant [ __ ] [ __ ]
join the parade non mais tu le fais
exprès là non mais ça va c'est un jeu de
bagnole regarde on dirait Bumbo la
petite automobile en version ch plus bon
c'est tout innocent c'est tout mignon
alors bon c'est une licence qu'on
connaît pas trop chez nous mais en vrai
ça serait un peu l'équivalant des jeux à
10 bouts il y a rien de sexuel dans le
jeu au contraire regarde-moi cette
petite [ __ ] [ __ ] tu la trouves pas
adorable hein moi je te dis quand je
vois les pare-chocs de cette [ __ ] [ __ ]
j'ai qu'une seule envie c'est de foncer
à carart Town de rentrer dans cette [ __ ]
[ __ ] et de la démarrer
Seb tu es là j'étais en train de
chercher notre
dignité tu as trouvé non après bon la
3DO n'a pas été qu'un gigantesque flop
il y a eu des trucs bien quand même par
exemple return fire excellent jeu de
Capture the Flag faisant partie du top 3
de la console ou star Fighter un jeu
très avancé techniquement he pour
l'époque avec un monde en 3D
destructible des cinématiques avec
doublage entre chaque mission et des
licences très connues ont commencé sur
3DO la toute première version de Need
for Speed par exemple est sortie sur 3DO
et effectivement le titre dit la vérité
hein le jeu a vraiment besoin de
[Musique]
vitesse bref la 3DO finalement n'aura
vécu que 1 an et demi dès 1994 la
Playstation et la Saturne sont annoncés
et à ce moment-là le grand public va
commencer a garder son argent pour
attendre la sortie des générations 32
bits les baisses de prix successives de
la console ne changeront rien le bateau
est déjà en train de couler et même au
niveau des développeurs ceux-ci vont
déserter la console puisque en 94 les
éditeurs ont déjà reçu leur kit de dev
pour la PS1 et vont donc commencer à
développer leur jeux pour la génération
de consoes suivante voire même changer
de console en cours de développement
Metal Gear solide par exemple était
prévu à la base pour être un jeu 3DO
avant de changer pour la PlayStation 1
en cours de route anecdote d'ailleurs
une 3DO 2 sera même prévue n de code
Bulldog avec une technologie nommée m2
censé être capable de rivaliser avec la
puissance de la Playstation mais de peur
de se foirer face à Sony ils n'en feront
rien et la technologie en question
finira dans des machines à café bref
c'est pas tout ça mais on a un dossier
de réclamation à faire
[Musique]